ALBERT MEYER: We've considered
arithmetic sums, where
each term is a fixed amount
larger than the previous term
by an additive amount.
Another kind of sum
called geometric sums
which, we're going
to look at now,
come about where
each sum is a fixed
multiple of the previous sum.
And these come up all the time
in lots of different settings.
And in this
particular case, we're
going to look at
an example of how
it applies to analyzing the
value of money in the future.
So let's begin with
a geometric sum.
And there's the
standard form of it.
Geometric sum is of the form
1 plus x plus x squared up
through the nth power of x.
And, for uniformity, notice
that 1 is actually x to the 0.
So we're taking the sum from
k equals 0 to n of x to the k.
Now, what I'd like to do is
find a nice closed form for this
without those
ellipses, and having
a growing number of terms n.
And there's a simple trick
with the arithmetic sum.
The way Gauss got
it and the way we
got it was by reversing the sum
and adding the things together.
This time the trick is
to multiply Gn by x.
Now what's that
going to do is it's
going to increase the
power of x in each term
by one, which is tantamount
to a right shift.
Let's look at that.
There's xG of n, so
1 times x, course,
I'm subtracting looking ahead.
So 1 times x is minus
x times x is x squared.
I'm going to subtract
it down through x
to the n minus 1 times x gives
me the x to the nth term.
And finally, I
have an extra term
from right shifting x to the
n to be x to the n plus 1.
Now let's do this subtraction.
But of course, I'm going
to align the terms up so
that they're easy to subtract.
And now all the terms
in the middle cancel,
which is very cool,
because we've just
figured out that Gn minus xGn
is 1 minus x to the n plus 1.
So we have this nice,
elegant formula.
Now I can factor out Gn
and I get a Gn times 1
minus x on the left.
And the result is that I get
the Gn is 1 minus x to the n
plus 1 over 1 minus x.
This is actually a formula that
we proved before by induction.
But when we did it
by induction, there
was no clue about who
was the clever person
to think of this formula.
Now you know how that
clever person found it.
And this is kind
of a standard trick
that we'll see more of when we
look at generating functions.
But for now, it's a
simple trick for getting
a nice closed form for a sum.
We refer to it as the
perturbation method.
You take the sum, you
perturb it a little,
see how it relates to itself,
get an arithmetic relation,
and solve for a
formula for the sum.
OK.
A geometric series--
I use the word
sum for a finite sum--
a geometric series
is when you take
an infinite sum.
So the infinite geometric
sum is the sum 1
plus x plus x
squared x to the n.
And it keeps going.
It's the sum from i equals
0 to infinity of x to the i.
And there's a simple
formula for that too.
It's even simpler actually.
Because the definition of
an infinite sum is it's
the limit of the truncated sums.
It's the limit of the
sum of the first n terms
as n goes to infinity,
assuming that limit exists.
And so for the value
of this infinite series
is the limit of Gn,
which is the sum up to n,
and let's look at that.
Well, Gn is 1 minus x to
the n plus 1 over 1 minus x.
So the limit of that, the limits
distribute pass the 1 down to--
and the x doesn't
have an n in it,
so it winds up being 1 minus the
limit as n approaches infinity
of x to the n plus 1
divided by 1 minus x.
And as long as x is
less than 1, x to the n
plus 1 is going to go
to 0, and I wind up
with this nice simple formula
that the infinite series,
the sum from i equals 0
to infinity of x to the i
is equal to 1 over
1 minus x, providing
that the magnitude
of x is less than 1.
OK.
That's the basics mathematical
preliminaries of geometric sums
and geometric series.
Now, let's look at a
typical application
having to do with the
future value of money.
Suppose we want to make
the following deal,
I promise I will pay
you $100 in one year
if you will pay me
a fixed amount now.
So let's call it x dollars.
And the puzzle is how
much money is $100 worth
if you can't have it now?
You can only have
it in one year.
It's worth x dollars.
How are we going to figure
out what x should be?
What would be a fair
amount for you to pay me
so that I'm willing to pay you
$100 in one year and it's fair,
nobody loses?
OK.
Well, here's the basic fact
that is the basis for evaluating
what the value of money
in the future is is I'm
going to assume that my bank
will pay me 3% interest.
This is a generous bank
in today's economy,
but it used to be
a stingy offer.
Interest rates in my lifetime
have ranged between about 17%
a year down to less
than 1% a year.
3% is a reasonable
number to play with.
So let's suppose that my
bank commits to paying me
3% interest on a deposit now.
That is to say, let's define
the bank rate, b, to be 1.03.
And the deal is
that the bank will
increase the money
that I have now
by a factor of b in one year.
OK.
Well, so if I deposit
your x dollars now,
that means I will have b
times x dollars in one year.
OK.
Assuming that the bank
is completely reliable,
there's no risk there and I get
exactly b times x in one year,
then I won't lose
any money providing
that b times x is greater
than or equal to 100.
I need the x dollars
you give me now
to be worth the $100
I'm supposed to pay you.
I'll come out ahead if bx is
greater than or equal to 100.
I'll loose if it's
less than 100.
And it's completely fair
if bx is equal to 100.
All right.
Well, that means
that x is simply
100 over b, which we
decided was 1.03 $97.09.
So $100 in one year is worth
$97.09 or normalizing to $1.00,
$1.00 in one year is worth
$0.97 essentially now.
Well, now we can shift
perspective a little bit
and think back a year.
So how much money did I need
last year in order to be worth
$1.00 today?
Well, by the same
reasoning, the bank
is going to pay me
b times r today.
So I need b times r
to equal a dollar.
In other words, r has
got to be 1 over ,
r is 1 over the bank rate.
So $1.00 a year ago is worth--
r dollars a year ago is worth
a dollar today.
And by the same reasoning,
n dollars paid in two years
is worth n times r paid in
one year, which is worth n
times r squared paid today.
So I can iterate this one
over bank rate factor,
and as time goes on, k years
out-- a value of n dollars paid
in k years is worth n
times r to the k today,
where r is 1 over the bank rate.
OK.
That's good to know.
Let's think about annuities now.
An annuity is a
contract that people by
to provide income for
themselves without risk.
So they will make
a deal typically
with an insurance
company where they
will pay a certain
amount of money
now to the insurance company,
and the insurance company
promises to provide
them a regular income
sometimes for life or
sometimes for a fixed period.
So let's look at an example.
I will pay you $100
a year for 10 years
if you will pay me
a fixed premium.
What should it be?
So I'm going to promise
as the insurance company
to pay you $100 a
year for 10 years.
I want you to pay me a
premium of y dollars now.
How much should you pay?
Well, let's think about it.
$100 in one year is
worth 100 times r.
And $100 in two years is
worth 100 times r squared.
And finally, $100 in 10 years is
worth 100 times r to the 10th.
So this is the
amount that I will
have to pay you in today's
dollars-- I need-- in order
to be paying you $100
a year for 10 years.
I need a total of this
much amount of money
now, because each of these
terms is the amount of money
that the $100 will be worth
paid to you that many years out.
Well, look at this sum.
If I factor out 100
r, I'm left with 100
r times the geometric sum
from 1 to r to the ninth,
where the base of the sum
is r, the factor is r.
Well, we have a nice
formula for that.
It's simply 1 minus r to
the 10th over 1 minus r.
And now plugging in
r equals 1 over 1.03.
I wind up with the conclusion
that this annuity is
worth $853.02 today.
My promise to pay you $1,000,
but spread out over the next 11
years, is worth $853.02
today, assuming that the bank
rate is 3% a year.
And that's a typical case
where geometric series come up.
And you'll see other
examples in problems.
Just a quick thing
to think about.
Suppose that the bank rates
rapidly increase, unexpectedly
increase.
The Fed finally gets
the economy moving
and interest rates
run up to 5%, say.
What happens on this annuity?
You've already paid me
the 853 and I've already
committed to paying you $100
a year for the next 10 years
starting in a year.
Who comes out ahead if
bank rates increase?
You come out ahead,
the deal stays fair,
or I come out ahead.
And I'll close by letting you
think about that question.